you got to interview bill yeah Bill
Clinton was the best he had just left
the White House he was at his office in
Harlem and I remember we went up there
Fred the guy whose birthday it was he
had this really funny idea but we get
there and his handlers are like you want
to do what now and like we have an idea
and they're like no ideas and she's like
the script we received as it says happy
birthday Fred I can't believe you made
it to 50. that's what we've approved you
have a different script and we're like
nope and she was very tough with us she
leaves game time her laptop's open until
the prompters out oh delete everything
this is exactly what I'm talking about
not thinking about Korean percussion
shut everything down he comes in and
she's like I'm sorry Mr President and
he's like Jessica I gotta get out of
here and I was like Mr President I have
an idea you remember Secret Service like
jumping up yeah I was like here's the
idea and I was like we made this and
he's like boys I love it